Today is uh
a not so special day, but it is the day
that I was born.
Um
and I'll read some stuff to you to piss
some people off in the comments just to
get things cracking. How's that sound?
Um
>> [laughter]
>> don't say I never did anything for you.
And so yeah, let's let's begin with the
tweet that has pissed everyone off.
Um your level of maturity is inversely
correlated with how much you want other
people to celebrate your birthday.
I've never admired anyone who insisted
his birthday was a big deal.
And uh I want to be really clear.
I think celebrating other people's
birthdays, absolutely. Honoring people
for being alive, for making this far,
all for it. I think the difference is
when you demand everyone do it for you.
I think that's where that's where you
get the uh this is my birth week, this
is my birth month, uh all that kind of
stuff. And I think that is uh
I think that is the wrong direction on
entitlement. Um my two cents, obviously,
you know, it's all it's worth and you
can take it for for what it is. Um
but uh on this uh not so special day,
um
one of my one of my team texted me this
thing, which is my favorite text of the
day.
Uh and he said, "Today is the day
Genghis Khan died and you were born."
Quote from the Khan, "There is no good
in anything until it is finished."
Um and I love that. Uh it's all about
starting what you finish. And so um I'll
read this to you cuz I've had a lot of
deeper thoughts on my mind lately as you
I think you when you hit whatever
deadlines you have.
Stand tall, don't crack, endure. You can
die tomorrow.
Today you do the only thing you can do.
You fight, you rage on, you do what you
came to do, you finish what you started.
No matter how much it costs, how long it
takes, or how much it hurts, because you
said you would.
Being cringe is the tax you pay when you
start to prove to the world that you
care more about what you want than how
you look.
One of the things that no one tells you
about delayed gratification is that once
you learn how to do it, you keep doing
it until you die. And then what you
delayed never happens.
Your goals will become easier to
accomplish when you become harder to
distract.
Whenever you get worried about not
achieving your goals, just remember
there's plenty of room at the top
because the majority of people are just
whiny, overweight, in debt little
You'll blow past them so fast
it'll look like they're standing still
because they are.
Be more dangerous than the forces that
hope to destroy you.
Make reality your today.
If you do not have courage, nothing else
matters.
So, with that being said, as our as our
premise for today, as we get cracking
and lacking,
um I thought I would uh I had I had this
little little video that I put some
notes together for you that I think you
might like.
Um
I think the goal of youth is optionality
and the goal of adulthood is commitment.
And these two things are at odds and I
think that at some point um
you have to reconcile which one you are.
Are you still stuck uh to your youth or
have you decided to become an adult?
An adult means you you eliminate
alternatives. You you walk through
one-way doors where you know you can't
walk back. Um
it's it's difficult to undo a marriage.
It's difficult to uh to impossible
uh possible but not really uh to undo a
child, right?
Um there are some one-way doors and I
think that um a lot of the best things
in life come on the other side of
commitments and I think that we have a
society that overemphasizes the value of
optionality
and
the reason that I said what I said
earlier, which is that if you delayed
your gratification,
optionality in a lot of ways is delaying
gratification. It's this idea that I'll
keep my options open.
But the thing is is that options only
have value when they are exercised.
And until you exercise them, they are
valueless. It's like dying at the end of
your life with as an ant that put a big
pile of crumbs that you never ate.
Right, at some point you have to pull
the trigger, you have to make the call,
you have to make the decision, you have
to cut off one future.
And so I think what's interesting is
that when you make that decision, it
means that you're going to decide that
one thing is more important than
another, which means that you also open
yourself up for criticism, which I think
a lot of people have a lot of difficulty
with.
And so, I want to give you 10
priorities, which make no sense at all,
because priority uh only recently in the
English vernacular uh was ever even used
in the plural. Until about 1950, it was
only priority. There's only one, because
only one thing can come first, right?
That's how it works.
But, here's our 10 things that most
people say are incredibly important. And
so, how how do we make sense of them?
So, number one, we have community,
giving back to your community.
We have romance, marriage, or partner.
We have parenting, for your children.
We have family, so to your siblings and
to your parents and your cousins, et
cetera.
We have recreation, so having fun,
relaxing. We have friends, spending
time, et cetera. We have your career,
your career aspirations, professional
aspirations.
Your physical health.
You have your spiritual health, and then
you've got your personal growth.
And so, that's 10 different elements
of life.
And if I were to ask you to prioritize
them, you will have a different priority
than the person next to you.
And so, the reason this is really
interesting is that if somebody looks at
your list and it is different than
theirs, they will call you as wrong,
because you do not live your life the
way that they would prefer.
And that is why they are
All right? Like, we don't have to
Like, we don't have to live according to
anyone else's preferences. You have to
follow the law, but besides that, you're
pretty much free to do whatever you
want. And we are so shackled by the idea
that other people
don't like what we're doing. It's like,
great, that's why they have their life
to do what they want to do with.
And so, what's interesting is that you
get to pick your regrets,
or
they will be chosen for you.
Real.
And so, whenever you invest in any of
those 10 things,
you pull away from others, right? If you
add an hour here, you take an hour from
here. We have a zero-sum life when it
comes to to time, right? And I do have
one interesting tactical strategy that
has helped me uh navigate these, but I
think the biggest one is just in
understanding that you will live an
imperfect life.
Period. Like, you cannot have a house by
the mountains
in isolation, and then also be walking
distance from restaurants, and then also
be on the beach, and also be ski and ski
out.
It doesn't work. And you can't have a
rich neighborhood if you want to be in
isolation. Now, all of these things are
okay to want. It's just that they will
not They literally sit in it They're
They're They're conflicting. They're
conflicting priorities.
And so, whenever you say and you make a
decision in your life, people will take
the equal opposite extreme. So, if it's
literally the the upset spouse, right?
You Your wife comes in and says, "Hey,
do I look good You know, do you look
good in this dress?" You say, "Yeah,
this You look great in this dress."
She's like, "Oh, so I don't look good
whenever I'm not wearing this dress?"
That is what people will do to whatever
decisions you make because they're too
cowardly to make them themselves. And I
really mean this. Like, people are
cowards.
They're They're They walk around afraid.
They They They They don't want
consequences. They don't want conflict
because they think that other people's
opinions about their lives matter more
than their own.
And it's ridiculous.
You must make trades.
You have to make a trade. And I love the
the definition of the word decidere
because it's Latin, but it The root of
it means to cut off. And it's just,
"What What future are we cutting off
today?" And I think that that is
And I think I as I'm, you know,
I've I'm at an annual little date for
myself, and so I look back on on the
last year.
Um and I think that your maturity level
is directly related to the amount of
commitments that you have made, the
number of people who rely on you.
And if those commitments are the
elimination alternative, it means that
you've cashed in optionality, right?
You've chosen to do things in lieu of
others.
And so, even if you were to divide your
life into 12 hours per day. So, let's
assume that you've got 4 hours for
eating, showering, you know, hygiene,
all the you living, right? And let's say
12 hours is your the hours that you can
just be focused, right? On anything.
If you were to divide those, we've got
those 10 things that I outlined. If you
were to give
an hour and, you know, 10 minutes per
day to each of those things,
it's like, okay, you're going to do an
hour and 10 minutes to your career, an
hour and 10 minutes to your
spirituality, an hour and 10 minutes to
your your your family, an hour and 10
minutes to your kids, an hour and 10
minutes to your uh relaxation time, an
hour and 10 minutes to your physical
health. Like, you go through it and it's
just like, I can't I can't do it all.
It's like, right, you have to make
trade-offs. It's what it is.
And so, I'll just say as somebody who
has, I would say, min-maxed to a degree
on some of those traits,
um
really helpful to just order them for
yourself. Which of these is most
important for you?
And, and here's the here's the bu- This
is the one tactical tip I've got. This
is this is it. This is my one tactical
tip.
Try to do things that check multiple
boxes.
So, for example, the reason that lifting
with friends is so viable to me, um is
that I lift with people I work with who
I'm also friends with. And so, it checks
off recreation, it checks off a degree
of of of career growth, it checks off
physical health. Um and so, I get three
or four boxes checked from this one
one activity. And so, I'm able to block
more time with it. And there's probably
some version of that for you that you
can do for two or three things. And I'm
not saying you're going to get
everything, but every once in a while
you can get lucky and you can just do
you can check a few boxes with one
action, right? No extra time. So, I
think that's a big W. Now,
I think that you will do the best that
you can to manage these things. And at
the end of your life, uh you will think
to yourself, it would have been nice
to do these other things.
But when you say that, you do that from
the position of having already earned
the benefit of your existing trade. And
so, what we want is the benefits of the
trades that we did not make and the the
of the ones that we did. And so, we look
at the benefits of a different priority
being first and then saying, "Man, it
would be nice if I was also
hyper-spiritual. It would also be nice
if I was in the best shape. It would
also be nice if I had the best marriage.
It would also be nice if I was a great
parent. It would also be nice."
etc. etc.
But you can't you can't trade everything
in. And so, basically like you get to
pick your regrets. You get to pick the
things that you say were less important.
Otherwise, they will be chosen for you.
And I think what's really interesting is
whenever I think this to its natural
end, I think to myself,
"I am the problem." So, let me explain.
Um
I think we always want what we can't
have. And I think this is an inherently
human trait, right? Single people want
to be married, married people want, you
know, uh to be single. Uh
Uh people with no kids want kids, people
who have kids want a night off,
employees want to start their own
business someday, employers are jealous
of how their employees can clock out and
not take their work home with them. Um
there's just countless examples of
whatever you don't have is what you
want. Because right now, everyone who's
listening to this, you have accomplished
things that you said would make you
happy.
Like there's something in your life
right now that earlier on in your life
you said, "If I had this, I would be
happy."
And yet here we are.
And so, whenever I think this, I just
think like I am the problem.
Like I am the constant. Like the the
constant source of dissatisfaction is
me.
Um
and it's just cuz we want it all.
But you you you go to a store
where there's 10 amazing shoes and each
shoe is $100.
And you have $100 in your wallet.
And in order to justify our decision, we
make everyone else feel bad about buying
a different set of shoes than us.
And it was just a choice. And I don't
think there's anything wrong with that.
Cuz a lot of people I think look at
um
you know, the life that we have, which I
think is, you know, super blessed, etc.
Um
But we've traded other things, you know,
we've traded other things. And I think
that if those things are more important
to you then like, good for you.
Seriously, like I
to the degree that you can possibly
believe a stranger on the internet, I
mean this from the bottom of my heart.
If you like the priorities that you
have,
then you won, dude. You won.
I got you won. You've already got it.
Like
like, you know,
like you're there.
Um I think where people get in trouble
is where they allow life to make these
priorities for them, right? They make
the They don't get to make the choices.
They they sit passively by and let
options expire.
And I think that's if there's anything
that
that I can hopefully, you know,
transfer, it's uh
you can be a master of your own life to
a degree if you can just say I'm willing
to give up these other things for the
things that I care about most.
And so, um
that's my that's my my two cents's. Take
those 10 things,
rank them 1 to 10, and then of those,
see which one you think is off as in
like, okay, I said this is number two,
but I don't think I'm really
putting number two out of 10 effort into
this. And I'll tell you two for me.
I think that I've been
I've been not as good of a husband as I
probably should have been. I probably
should have spent um
more time with Layla and I'm going to
prioritize doing that and I've started
to do that. Um and I think that I've
I I have
I have a higher desire for friendship
than I have in my current life.
Like I see friends sporadically. I'd say
outside of me like lifting, which is
basically almost the entirety of the
recreational like friend time that I
have. Um I had a buddy of mine who was
here for my birthday, which was awesome.
Um that Layla kind of surprised me with,
which was super sweet of her. Um
and those are very like filling to my
soul.
And I think that um
I'm going to make trades
in the coming future where I'm going to
decrease some of these other stats
in order to make some room here where I
think that the incremental return that
I'll get on losing an hour on call it
career and adding an hour somewhere
else,
uh I will have a little bit less
but my overall life benefit will be
higher. And so I think the the meta of
this is
the game that you want to play.
And so I'll give you an interesting
story on this. So, I can't remember the
name of the founder, but he was on um
David Senra's podcast
and uh really smart guy, sold his
company for like $10 million or
something like that. And he said you
always want to look for the most
dominant game. And I was like, "Huh,
this is a really interesting concept."
He said, "So, for example, MySpace lost
to Facebook because Facebook had a more
dominant game that they were playing."
And so MySpace, for example, wanted to
get uh the most uh users. That was the
game they were playing. That was the
metric they're optimizing around.
Facebook was optimizing around monthly
active users, MAU, which then became
kind of like the social media norm in
terms of what so you know, social
platforms are measured by. But that one
little misstep in terms of what metric
they were op- optimizing around mean
meant that Facebook was literally paying
playing a superior game.
And so in thinking about this concept of
like there are there are subset superset
games. There are some games that even if
you're just playing them, you beat
everyone else because the game that
you're optimizing for is just a superior
game.
And so I think that um I think this is
entirely individual, but if we look at
these 10 categories that I outlined. So,
I'll repeat them again for those who are
just joining.
Let's see if I can get my little list
up.
So, the list is this. You've got
community, you've got romance / partner,
parenting for your kids, you've got your
family, uh so siblings and your parents,
you've got recreation and rest and fun,
uh friends, uh career, physical health,
spiritual, and then personal growth,
right? Those are kind of like 10
categories
of living.
And I think that some people make their
entire game one of them.
And I think the
I think the larger game is trying to win
at life.
And realizing that each of these are
components of it. And I don't know if uh
And I think that you will have different
And when I say this prioritization
thing, I like
people also have a hard time allowing
other people to change.
Cuz it just makes them it's just
intellectually more uh more work. And so
it's like, "How dare you change your
mind?"
"In [snorts] front of me. How dare you?"
Right, "How dare you be really into your
physical health and then decide that
you're
your your kids are more important and so
you don't work out as much." Right, "How
dare you?"
And so I think that like
people get upset because they're
weak.
Like people are are paths like people
people are so
small-minded.
Self-interested.
And the things they will say in no way
have complete context on your life.
And so it's like trying to listen to 100
people that know two sentences about
you.
None of their opinions matter. Cuz the
person who has the most context on you
is you. You're the only one who has to
live with you.
And I know obviously it's hard because
when we're kids we're raised to listen
to other people and shame has a very
good place in society. You should feel
bad if you do things that hurt people
and like those things work for enforcing
social rules. So it's this very odd, you
know, dichotomy between, you know, it's
good to have other people on the outside
telling you,
"Hey, maybe you shouldn't be a
ass."
But at the same time being able to
differentiate between call it
uh rule
law-breaking activity and rule-breaking
activity, which I see as very different.
So we have legal laws, right? That have
written out consequences that we have
determined, like it or not, that you
have to abide by to live in whatever
area you're in, right? But then there's
rule-breaking that's spoken and
unspoken. And so, many of you get
different cultures, different rules,
your parents had different rules. And
it's realizing that there are no
consequences, or the consequences that
happen from those rules are not nearly
as severe as we think they are. And so,
the reason that I opened the book with
offers
with only three words, which is there
are no rules. I guess that's four words.
Um
is cuz it's always a reminder myself of
like, what rules am I being weighed down
by right now that I'm choosing like what
box am I living in that I'm unaware of
that has invisible walls that is keeping
me in.
Real quick, I'm going to show you the
exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to 100
million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish. I've now done multiple
times. And so, I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
headcount increases that you need to get
through. And I broke each of these down
by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, uh service
businesses, brick and mortar, all of
this, and it works. And it's my gift to
you. It's absolutely free. And so, the
link's in the description, but you just
go acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you all free.